foreign
animal Transformers dude yes it's
wonderful to see that what began as a
toy line and animated show in the 80s is
still going strong now in many
iterations especially on the big screen
this is live action offering number
seven serving as a sequel to 2018
certified fresh Bumblebee and a bit of a
prequel to the first Transformers movie
from 2007. but really it's just its own
thing too and while there's no Shia
LaBeouf there is some Michael Bay
involvement and that's why we're here to
break it all down for you so here's
everything you need to know before you
go see Transformers rise of the Beast
okay friends let's put our cars in
Transformer mode and get on with it
while the term soft reboot was once
Loosely tossed around about this film
what we do know is that it's Loosely
based on the computer animated series
Beast Wars Transformers which ran from
1996 to 1999 and includes an 86 fresh
per season on the Tomato Meter now this
movie will incorporate themes and
characters from that show which
introduced some new kinds of
Transformers called Predacons and
maximals it is very popular with Die
Hard fans of the franchise not to
mention all those 90 kids who used to
watch like me relax a mirage remember
now critic Tim Weber from CBR said that
this series quote one Fan's over with
incredibly strong writing with solid
characters and complex occasionally dark
storylines now in terms of the movies
rise of the Beast Falls between we're
told it takes place in 1994 while
bumblebee happens in 1987 and the films
by Michael Bay who's a producer on Rise
of the Beast by the way took place in
the Arts in early 2010s but is it a
prequel to those movies nobody has been
overly quick to really offer a heartfelt
yes but as a quick refresher bumblebee
Stars Haley Seinfeld as a young woman
who discovers a broken and battle scar
Transformer named Bumblebee who ended up
becoming one of our favorites and helps
him get back on his you know tires
foreign
flick Transformers well you pretty much
just need to know that Shia LaBeouf was
in it pretty good right
uh I'd say a solid b-minus and the
Autobots and Decepticons were battling
it out with the fate of humanity hanging
into balance obviously but really given
the Beast Wars connection and
introduction of an all-new cast this
film is really ready to stand on its own
and speaking of a brand new cast let's
have a look at who was acting with
tennis balls against a giant green
screen and who was actually yelling at a
microphone in a booth aka the live
action and voice cast so leading the way
in front of the camera is Anthony Ramos
of in the Heights Fame and Dominique
Fishback from the deuce and providing
the voices for the many new machines is
a loaded cast and when I say loaded I
mean loaded of folks that include Pete
Davidson who is pretty much in every
movie ever now Ron Perlman Peter
Dinklage the amazing Michelle yo and of
course Peter Cullen aka the longtime
voice of Optimus Prime okay that was
really bad but I tried
now rise of the Beast was directed by
Stephen cable Jr best known for his work
on the certified fresh Creed 2. and he
is no doubt looking for a second
straight knockout with this one now as
far as what all these actors will be
saying and doing we can tell you some
stuff about the plot like I said it
takes place in 1994 in Brooklyn New York
where Ramos and fishback's characters
are archaeologists and somehow end up in
the middle of an ancient conflict
between three factions of Transformers
the maximals terracons and Predacons all
robots that transform into robotic
animals I mean this is the coolest thing
ever and of course let's not forget the
Autobots and Decepticons are still doing
their thing you know being mad at each
other and all that good stuff so we
can't tell you too much about the plot
but we can tell you a bit more about the
new Transformers that you're gonna meet
now based on what we learned from the
Beast Wars animated series we know that
the terracons are bad if the name didn't
already give that away as in they are a
faction of Decepticon in the film
they're headlined by the villain Scourge
who transforms into a huge Peterbilt
logging truck and ironically is voiced
by the hugely talented Peter Dinklage
maximals on the other hand are good guys
heroic and influenced by the Autobots in
the movie Michelle yo is the voice of a
maximal known as eraser who transforms
into a peregrine falcon and Ron Perlman
is a voice of Optimus primal who
transforms into a gorilla gotta say best
name ever joining our friends Bumblebee
and Optimus Prime in the Autobots
category is Pete Davidson's Mirage
character who transforms into a Porsche
964. now if the trailer wants us to
believe anything it's that the biggest
threat in Rise of the Beast will be
coming from the villain Unicron a giant
Transformer that snacks on you know
planets how big can this guy be uh he
eats planets so like way bigger than a
planet now I usually just like to grab a
handful of almonds but I mean hey to
each their own okay friends that's
everything you need to know before you
go see Transformers rise of the beast in
theaters June 9th let them come
and if you don't know I'm Naz Perez and
thanks for watching and be sure to rate
and review this film at
rottentomatoes.com
foreign
[Music]